♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est ici, en septembre 2017,
que 162 guérilleros du Front
19 des FARC ont déposé les armee
et les paramilitaires pendant
des décennies dans les montagnes
alentours, la Sierra de Santa
Marta et la Cordillère
du Perija. Dans cet espace
de formation et
de réincorporation, il y en a
24 en Colombie en vertu
de l'accord de paix de 2016.
350 personnes tentent de
survivre dans ce petit village.
Mais ce n'est pas facile.
Les habitations soeeeee
temporaires, une pièce de
4 mètres par 6 par foyer
que ceux qui peuvent essaient
d'agrandir. Les sanitaires
sont communs.
Il y a une petite épicerie,
une salle à manger
et une auberge pour
les visiteurs et bientôt,
espère-t-on, pour les touristes.
Le dirigeant de la coopérative
Freddy Escobar nous montre
les plans de la future Citadelle
de la Paix financée uniquement
par l'aide internationale car
le gouvernement d'Ivan Duque
fait tout depuis 4 ans
pour torpiller l'application
de l'accord de paix.
L'Epapapapapapas construit
une seule demeure en cinq ans.
La première maison sera celle
du projet Ecotour de Tierra
Grata, le plus prometteur.
ririririririllero Felix est
le guide du clou de l'Ecotour :
le campement. L'idée : faire
revivre aux touristes la vie
quotidieRCRCRCRCRCRC dans
la forêt pendant la guerre.
Les cambuche : un matelas
de terre et de feuilles
entre quatre piquets.
Au centre du campement :
la habla, lieu de réunio
pour la formation, les cours,
les fêtes aussi, le débat
sur les nouvelles de la radio
tous les soirs à 18h.
À gauche le quartier
des commandants. Plus loin,
la rancha, la cuisine,
l'infirmerie, jusqu'à la fosse
d'aisances, les chontos.
Tout y est reproduit
à l'identique, mais à petite
échelle. Une quinzaine
de touristes sont déjà venus
y passer 24 heures, dit Felix.
Et ils ont eu une belle
expérience, pas la moindre
nuisance ni le moindre bruit,
cellulaires éteints.
L'histoire de Felix est
touchante. Abandonné par
ses parents à 10 ans, il devient
paysan chez un oncle.
Une vie difficile, un mariage
désastreux, beaucoup
d'humiliation.
Alors, il s'enrôle dans
la guérilla. C'était bien parce
que là, personne n'était jamais
humilié.
♪ ♪ ♪
Pas question de renier le passé
des FARC : dans la maison de
la mémoire, les objets
souvenirs, peintures
sur l'histoire de
la violence, vieilles radios,
les uniformes, la bibliothèque
qui était restée
la forêt jusqu'en 2019.
Marcos Guevara, il a gardé son
nom de guerre, est le directeur
de l'Ecotour.
"Nous voulons un tourisme de
mémoire et de culture.aiaiaiaiae
réconciliation. Avec des
sentiers de randonnée et
d'observation d'oiseaux. Il y a
des espèces uniques danslelelelc
laquelle les FARC étaient en
symbiose, c'était une question
de survie que de se cacher
de l'aviation."
Marcos met la main à la pâte
pour la construction de la
maison de l'Écotour. Ensuite
viendront les habitations pour
les familles. Tout est fabriqué
sur place...
... la charpenterie,
la ferronnerie, les blocs de
ci
Tout ça grâce à l'aide
internationale. Mais ça ne
suffit pas. La communauté survit
a peine à cause du non-respect
de l'accord de paix par
le gouvernement.
FREDDY ESCOBAR, dirige
Coopérative Paz del Cesar :
"On est loin de l'autonomie
et de la réincorporation
économique, sociale, et encore
moins politique."
De bonne source, la majorité
des 24 communautés
de réinsertion sontcucucucucucus
et discordes internes.
♪ ♪ ♪
La branche politique des ex-FARC
c'est le parti Comunes.
Au Congrès, Luis Alberto Alban
Urbano, alias Marcos Calarca,
ex-négociateur des FARC,
entame son second mandat
de représentant. C'est l'un
des dix sièges réservés d'office
aux FARC en vertu de l'accord
de paix. C'est lui qui nous
a dirigé vers Tierra Grata par
d'autres régions sont trop
dangereuses.
332 ex-FARC ont été assassinés
depuis 2016, dit le député.
La haine est entretenue parle gt
efforcé de ne pas appliquer
l'accord de paix.
Quatre ans de perdus.
En ville, la réinsertion
des FARC n'est pas facile non
plus. Mais il y a des réussites
comme La Brasserie Alternativa.
De la guérilla a la bière
artisanale et la restauration
pour Manuel Bolivar.
Après un début modeste,
cette grande maison du quartieru
plus qu'un restaurant,
une maison d'art et de culture.
Un succès dû aux bons repas
et a une bière brasséeicicicicis
sous l'étiquette Alternativa.
Une microbrasserie qui
a sa propre marque, la Roja,
la rouge, mais qui doit
tout importer.
... importer tout, orge, houblon
car les terres colombiennes,
confisquées pendant la guerre
par des grands propriétaires,n'.
Il y a quatre mois, Manuel
a découvert une bombe dans
une toilette du deuxième étage.
Il a pu la faire désamorcer,
mais il a revécu la peurtatatats
terroristes.
Le soir même, 400 personnes
sont venues faire la fête
en soutien à la Casa
Alternativa.
Manuel y a lancé un Nouveau
cocktail : la bombe.
Manuel et tous les ex-FARC
comptent sur le nouveau
président pour
l'accord qu'ils ont signé
en promettant.
... plus jamais la guerre.